for some actors Friday Night Lights
served as a springboard for future
successes for others it was the pinnacle
of their career here is what the cast of
Friday Night Lights has been up to since
their time walking the halls of Dillon
High although playing jeff Metcalf on
ABC sitcom homefront lit the flame of
Kyle Chandler's acting career it was the
role of Eric Taylor head coach of the
Dillon Panthers football team on Friday
Night Lights that truly poured gasoline
on it as Taylor Chandler gave an
incredibly believable grounded
performance that perfectly captured a
teacher and family man the role even
earned him a well-deserved Emmy win for
lead actor in a Drama Series in 2011
after officially hanging up his whistle
in 2011 Chandler became a hot name in
Hollywood he's appeared in a slew of
well-received movies including the wolf
of Wall Street
first man and Manchester by the sea and
in 2015 he dipped back into TV starring
in Netflix's Golden Globe nominated
series bloodline while the respected
actor has enjoyed a wildly successful
decade it appears as though the Godzilla
king of the monsters star hasn't let
Fame change his priorities in a recent
interview with Men's Journal Chandler
discussed the life-changing decision to
leave Los Angeles and move his family to
a small town outside of Austin Texas in
order to focus on family life with his
wife and two daughters faces for
apparently Connie Britton was destined
to play a football coaches wife the Spin
City veteran not only played Sharon
Gaines the wife of Billy Bob Thornton's
coach games in 2004 Friday Night Lights
movie but also Tammy Taylor the high
school guidance counselor married to
coach Eric Taylor in NBC's Friday Night
Lights television series as Tami Britton
shown as a strong-willed mother and
devoted wife nabbing a pair of Emmy
nominations in 2010 and 2011 after
Friday Night Lights Britton took on the
role of Vivien Harmon on the first
season of Ryan Murphy's wild horror
series American Horror Story
although Britton was excited to play a
different type of part she was a little
nervous about some of the show's risque
scenes according to the actress I needed
to shake things up but also worried my
god what are people going to think when
they see Tammy Taylor having sex with a
man in a rubber suit
fortunately Britain's time on American
Horror
story did nothing but boost her profile
and she soon found herself starring in a
plethora of both films and television
series alike perhaps most notably as
Rayna Jaymes from CMT's mega hit
Nashville britain has also played
notable parts and shows like 930 John
and Smith as well as movies like
American ultra and bombshell so it's
safe to say she's keeping busy after
stealing America's heart playing
troubled teen with a heart of gold Tim
Riggins on Friday Night Lights Taylor
Kitsch seemed destined for the big time
while splitting time walking the halls
of Dillon high Kitsch appeared in small
roles in a couple of blockbuster action
movies including snakes on a plane and
x-men origins Wolverine but audiences
were excited to see what he could do as
a leading man unfortunately things
didn't quite pan out as expected in that
regard after Friday Night Lights rapped
Kitsch landed two leading parts the
first was as the titular character in
Disney's ambitious sci-fi blockbuster
John Carter which completely bombed in
the box office reportedly losing 200
million dollars and the other was as
lieutenant Alex hopper in battleship
which also ended up being a massive flop
while the actor bounce back with smaller
roles and successful projects like lone
survivor and HBO's True detective
Hollywood still seems hesitant to cast
him as a lead again the savages star
still gets work from Hollywood most
recently in the Chadwick Boseman led 21
bridges but much like fellow Friday
Night Lights alum Kyle Chandler he
actually lives in Austin Texas where he
spends his time playing guitar and doing
photography although he may not have
left Texas don't expect Tim Riggins to
show up in a series reboot anytime soon
he vowed in 2019 there's no way if you
want to give me twenty five million
dollars I'll do it but that's my price
it's hard to reminisce on episodes of
Friday Night Lights without Minka
Kelly's Lyla Garrity coming to mind the
Panthers cheerleader had a real girl
next door vibe about her and although
her dating exploits often muddied her
reputation she was a staple to the
series success the show catapulted Kelly
into the limelight and she was even
crowned Esquire sexiest woman alive in
2010 fresh off her Friday Night Lights
Fame Kelly starred in the 2011 horror
film
The Roommate which attempted to
capitalize on the fact that she and
Gossip Girls Leighton Meester look
uncannily similar
also add roles on network TV shows like
NBC's Parenthood and ABC's ill-fated
Charlie's Angels reboot but she really
didn't have another noteworthy gig until
she played dove on DC's Titans in 2018
Boy Wonder
while Kelly has managed to fly below the
radar in terms of filmography she has
stayed in the tabloids for other reasons
namely her love life much like Lyla
Garrity
Kelly's dating life has been a bit of a
roller coaster over the past decade
she's been linked to an abundance of
celebrities ranging from Chris Evans to
Sean Penn
sounds like Lila doesn't just have eyes
for football players after all although
it's been several years since her last
time playing Tyra Collette Adrianne
Palicki still has her own ideas on where
she thinks Dillon's resident bad girl
would be today
she told Texas Monthly Riggins is still
in Dillon Texas and married to Tyra
they're a messed-up version of Coach and
Tami because he still Riggs but he's
coaching and she's now the counselor
it's the next evolution while it may
have been tough to say farewell to the
angsty Texas teen Palicki has achieved a
respectable career since her time on
Friday Night Lights especially in the
butt-kicking genre she starred in 2012
Spore Lee reviewed remake of Red Dawn
before appearing in major action
blockbusters GI Joe retaliation and John
wick and she also gained notoriety by
playing fan favorite super heroine
Mockingbird on ABC's agents of shield
most recently the Legion vet has been
showcasing her comedic prowess alongside
Family Guy Seth MacFarlane on Fox's Star
Trek spoof the Orville s commander Kelly
Grayson Palicki plays the first officer
and ex-wife of McFarland's captain Edie
Mercer although the show takes place in
outer space certain aspects of it feels
similar to the Dillon High alum she told
Vanity Fair I can compare this to Friday
Night Lights in a sense the reason it's
so grounded is because it's grounded in
reality you could be taking us off the
spaceship and have the exact same
situations happen from rural Texas to
outer space there's apparently no
telling how high Tyra Collette will fly
in the first episode of Friday Night
Lights Matt Saracen a shy awkward nobody
gets a chance to shine as the Dillon
Panthers quarterback much like his
character it was also Zach Gilford first
opportunity to show what he could do s
listen Guilford captured the essence of
a high school average Joe and really
became one of the more relatable
characters on the show your dad's not
able to see what I see your different
kids in you were two weeks ago you are
perhaps it was this natural underdog
quality that helped him land roles in
various projects after Friday Night
Lights wrapped including horror flicks
the purge anarchy and Devils do while
Finn roles are all well and good you
have to imagine that one of Guilford's
most unique credits was playing the
boyfriend in Taylor Swift's music video
for her song hours most recently you can
see Gilford on NBC's good girls where he
plays Mae Whitman's ex-husband Greg it's
good to see that Matt returned to his
home network Dallas born actor Jesse
Plemons may have been an unknown when he
first played lovable loser turned high
school jock Landry Clarke in Friday
Night Lights but that isn't the case
anymore the emmy-nominated star has been
all over the map since 2011 with a wide
ranging acting resume
aside from Landry he is perhaps most
recognized as sadistic Todd Jesse
pinkman's captor and torturer in the
wildly popular Breaking Bad but he has
also played prominent roles on the big
screen starring in movies like Black
Mass bridge of spies and game night
Clemens was also one of the lead
characters on the second season of FX's
anthology series Fargo while the show
brought his career success in many
facets including his first Emmy
nomination it also greatly enhanced his
personal life by introducing him to his
co-star and future fiance spider-man
star Kirsten Dunst the two were engaged
in January of 2017 and welcomed their
first son Ennis in mid 2018 while
Plemons stays busy in Hollywood most
recently appearing in Netflix's
oscar-nominated gangster movie the
Irishman he's loving fatherhood saying
it's the best man it's so hard to put
into words all the clichés are true what
every parent tells you coach Taylor
would be proud Aimee Teegarden was only
16 when she was cast as Julie Taylor the
strong-willed daughter of coach Eric and
Tami Taylor and Friday Night Lights
although it was her first pilot she had
enough advice from some of her more
experienced co-stars to know that the
show was a rare opportunity
she told nylon Kyle Chandler I remember
he used to say to us you kids you have
no idea how
good you have it you have no idea so I
think at the time we all kind of just
really tried to enjoy it as much as
possible and it was just such a special
show and it was an amazing time in my
life since Friday Night Lights ended
Teegarden has kept one foot in network
television first starring as Emory
whitehill on CW's romantic sci-fi series
star-crossed and then as Ella Benjamin
on ABC's notorious although her film
career never really caught fire she has
popped up in the occasional horror movie
including 2011 scream 4 and 2007 teens
rings and she recently starred in the
2009 teen hallmark movie once upon a
Christmas miracle out of all the Friday
Night Lights stars Teegarden arguably
looks the most different today in fact
most people apparently don't recognize
her if they see her about she told Fox 4
1 1 it's funny it takes people a hot
second to recognize me because when I
was in Friday Night Lights I had super
blonde hair and bangs and I was 16 when
I started that show poor Jason Street
the one time quarterback had such a
promising future ahead of him prior to
his devastating injury and Friday Night
Lights pilot placing him in a wheelchair
for the remainder of the show
fortunately for Scott Porter the actor
playing Street Friday Night Lights was
just the beginning of a highly
successful acting career porter
officially hung up his cleats after the
series third season but he did come back
to make an appearance in season 5 after
that he continued to work in TV most
notably as George Tucker in Heart of
Dixie he has also appeared in a plethora
of movies throughout the years including
prom night and Speed Racer
while the Nebraskan actor has shared on
screen steamy scenes with Minka Kelly
and Rachel Bilson when the camera goes
off he has a devoted happily married
husband and father in 2013 his wife
Kelsey Mayfield Porter was diagnosed
with Huntington's disease a serious
neurological condition that affects
brain cells in response the couple has
been working to raise awareness and more
importantly how to end the disease
Porter revealed I want them to know that
you don't have to pass the gene down we
did something called PGD IVF it's
genetic testing for embryos and you can
make sure that you don't pass it down
any longer mccoy my son is clean that
Huntington's gene will end with my wife
as Brian smash Williams guys Charles got
to channel his inner boobie miles to
portray a talented yet egotistical
athlete how
the actor in real life is apparently
very different from his on-screen
counterpart according to Charles when we
all first got cast we all went out to
lunch with executive producer Peter Berg
we're talking and talking he goes you're
really different from your character I
mean really different and I'm like okay
so should I get my burger to go am I
fired since Friday Night Lights the New
York City bred actor has held minor
roles in several movies and television
shows he appeared in 2010 Sault
alongside Angelina Jolie and more
recently an NBC spin-off prequel series
taken but Gaius is perhaps best known
for playing dr. Shane Ross in the later
seasons of ABC's Grey's Anatomy we can't
wait to see what he does next check out
one of our newest videos right here Plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]